so yeah so this is the last talk of this
week and we are very happy to have greg
valiant from stanford to talk about the
estimation beyond the idea setting so
take away greg
okay so so thank you and sorry i'm uh
i'm not there in person um
good so i was going to talk about i
guess two different
um
two different sorts of challenges that
happen when you're trying to do learning
or estimation beyond the
the kind of iid data setting
they're quite different
and it's okay if we don't get to both
parts
okay so the first part
is based on some joint work with justin
chen who's a phd student at mit
and paul valiant
i'm going to appear that this past
eureps
so as a warm-up
i wanted to start with
a very you know the most simple possible
setting um and a sort of surprising
result that i wasn't aware of um
so suppose we're just trying to estimate
the bias of a coin
in a worst case optimal way and i'll
explain what that means in a minute
okay so i have a coin there's a
the coin has some some secret bias
and your job is to guess the bias
okay so here's my uh here's my coin
and suppose i'm just gonna flip the coin
once okay so i flip it once
um
and
your job is to um
guess the bias of the coin in a way
that's going to minimize the expected
error the expected squared error of your
guess
in the worst case sense so in the worst
case overall possible
bias is p
so suppose i know
your algorithm i know what you're going
to i know how you're going to map an
outcome to a guess and i pick the p that
makes that sort of maximizes this
expected error and then i flip that coin
what algorithm do you use that minimizes
this okay so let's let let's let's uh
let's try something so
um
suppose i'm gonna flip the coin okay so
i flipped it and we get a zero
and now based on this data point your
job is to guess the bias of the coin in
this sort of uh worst case optimal way
so um so yeah so what's your guess going
to be
so some someone in the audience should
should get something it's okay if it's
not
um okay so uh
um
okay that's not a bad guess um
yeah
and okay let's do one more guess one
more guess
zero yeah
zero okay okay so uh so the the right
answer is actually uh halfway between
the those two guesses
so i clean that the sort of worst case
optimal and again we'll parse what we
mean exactly by this
um
sort of mapping is if the outcome's a
zero
um guess that the bias is a quarter
and if the outcome's a one so by
symmetry you'll guess that the bias is
three quarters um
so i guess you know to show that this is
sort of optimal requires a tiny bit of
calculation but just as an intuition
suppose if the outcome is zero you guess
that the bias is zero if the outcome is
one you guess that the bias is one
well in that case if the bias is close
to zero or close to one you'll do very
well in expectation but if the bias was
a half
then your
your squared error will be well a half
squared it will be a coordinate
um and
so in that case they have worst possible
p would correspond to being exactly a
half
and the best p would be kind of p equals
zero p equals one from the perspective
of your algorithm
and
um this this sort of proposed algorithm
where if you see zero you predict a
quarter if you see one you predict three
quarters um this sort of trades off the
error at p equals a half versus the
error at p equals you know zero or one
and it sort of balances it out um and by
some sort of you know
convexity type argument it intuitively
it seems like this is going to be the
best thing
um and you know if you actually compute
this
um for all values of p that are between
something like zero point sorry that are
between point zero seven and point
nine three this is going to get better
expected error than uh
um than if you say just outputted zero
if you see zero and one if you see one
okay let's let's do this for two flips
so suppose i flip the coin two times
and
again sort of by symmetry
if you see a zero and a one
or a one and a zero you should predict a
half right by so by symmetry if
you know half the things you see are
uh are one half or zero you should be
estimating a half
so the only question is kind of what
should you predict if you see two zeros
or three c two ones
and again by symmetry you know the
answer for the zeros should be one minus
the answer for the
if you see two ones so really the only
question is if you flip two zeros
uh what are you going to estimate
um what's your estimate going to be um
does anyone want to throw out i guess
1 6
yeah not bad um so it ends up being
so we'll see exactly what this
expression is it's going to i mean this
expression will have some square root uh
you know some square roots in it um
but yeah it's not too far from a sixth
but uh yeah it's uh
0.2 roughly
um
good okay and um
uh
okay so so so i'm spilling the beans so
so if you flip um k times
the optimal from this kind of worst case
perspective
estimator
it takes the empirical estimate the
median of the samples and it's going to
regularize it it's going to smush it a
little bit towards a half
and it regularizes it towards a half
with this weight that's kind of one over
the square root of the number of flips
plus one
okay so it's uh
um
and
um and this you know turns out this was
uh has been known for
um actually over 70 years so so this
there was a paper on this problem by
hajj and uh lehman
i feel like i misspelling one of these
names but that's okay um in annals of
statistics in 1950
and in the paper they sort of say that
someone else knew this earlier i think
ruben maybe knew it even earlier but
maybe it wasn't published
[Music]
good so one thing that's surprising
about this just uh just to sort of uh
um
so okay so what's not surprising is that
you're going to kind of when k is small
you'll mush things a bit towards the
house
what i found surprising and what sort of
this
paper ends up
um
so claiming should be surprising in some
sense
is that the um this estimate is linear
in that it's a linear function of the
sample mean
and there's no reason that
uh
you know
there's no reason that you would
necessarily guess that the right answer
would be this linear function of the
sample
okay um
good before i go on is there any
questions about
either what this specific problem is or
what you know what these numbers mean or
how to think about this
and just out of curiosity um
is anyone in the audience had anyone in
the audience actually known about this
formula
one person is putting up their hands i
don't know if you can see it but my
question is can you define exactly sorry
what you mean by uh blah blah blah for
the worst case p
so okay
so
um
okay so given the estimator so your
estimator takes
the outcomes and maps it to some
some prediction
for some fixed true bias p
like suppose my bias is you know a third
um
so for a fixed bias you can say what's
the expected squared error of your
estimate
right
and that's kind of the natural metric
say for measuring
um and
here we're going to be work
we're concerned with um
[Music]
this expected squared error of your
estimate
but where you take the
maximum over all the possible biases p
um
sorry sorry i can't i can't hear um but
does that make sense
yeah it made sense thanks sorry yeah and
and again like if you have a bound on
this worst case uh
you know expected squared error um then
um yeah you can make the claim that
whatever the true bias is
um i have an estimator where the you
know the expected error is uh is long
right
so no matter what the true bias is this
is
which is which is a nice bound to have
right you don't need to
um
okay and of course in this case maybe
it's not super exciting because um you
know as k gets large just the you know
the the average of your samples is going
to converge well and that's
uh and that's fine but
okay good
any any other questions
this this is great and i'm very happy to
learn it
but it also seems to show that where
uh biased coin flips are concerned
the squared error is a wacky loss
function
oh okay good so what why do you say why
did you say that
well
because there are other loss functions
like for instance the log likelihood
which would give the more natural
estimator
and it's not as if our noise is gaussian
and
why in the world would we care about the
squared error in this case anyway
besides the fact that we care about it
in lots of other places
where distributions are
are gaussian
but i i i
this is a snarky question this is
awesome thank you for showing it
yeah
um
okay so so good so um and yeah that that
point's certainly valid um
[Music]
although you know for for other settings
and for other losses um
you know one
can get
strange
similarly strange answers too um but um
but yeah i know that that's certainly
valid
good okay so um
let me
um
let me give an alternate formulation of
this problem which will be the jumping
off point for what we're really going to
talk about
okay so again you know this problem was
you know we're flipping a coin k times
and we're trying to estimate the bias of
the coin
um
in an optimal
sort of perspective from the you know
square expected squared error from a
worst case perspective let me phrase
this an alternate way
so suppose we're
given
n different binary outcomes
sorry suppose there are n different
binary outcomes out there x1 through xn
and there's no you know there's no coins
behind these dexes these are just some
values that are sitting out there in the
universe
and now suppose we're going to be given
a uniformly random set of k of these uh
outcomes so for example suppose we're
we're told well x sub 15 equals 1 x of
19 is one you know blah blah blah except
100 is
zero and so on
so given this
random
subset of k of these values our goal is
going to be estim the goal is going to
be to estimate the overall mean of all
of these values
again so as to minimize the
worst case expected error
and let me let me write that out so
um
so again so we're we're trying to find
an estimator some function f
that maps these k
kind of observations to some prediction
and we're going to try to find the
estimator which minimizes
the worst case the maximum over
possible values that these x's have
of the
expected error
where again the expectation will be over
the choice of which of these k things we
see
so the expectation is over a uniformly
random set of k of these things
and what we care about again is say the
squared error the difference the square
the difference between our prediction
and the true mean of these things
squared
okay so i claim that um
you know as as n goes to infinity as the
number of these underlying values goes
to infinity
this problem is exactly the same as
we're given k
independent flips of a coin
where the can bias of the coin
corresponds to the true average value of
these x's
and and this is the same problem as what
we just talked about
does that make sense
so
um
good
so
um so in the case um
in the case where what we observe is a
subset of you know k a uniformly random
subset of k of these observations
um
you know there's this nice beautiful
closed form
uh
solution to this optimization problem
and you know the question that we're
going to think about is well
what if the observations are not drawn
in a uniformly are not a uniformly
random subset of k what if the
observations are drawn according to some
other sort of distribution
how can we still try to solve this
problem okay so suppose um
okay so we're gonna step back a little
bit and come back
uh you know come back to this um but
basically
we're thinking about the setting where
we have these
you can think of there well
we'll come back to this um
okay so
stepping back a little bit
you know it would be really great if we
could be able to actually estimate um
some statistics
of some underlying populations in the
case where the data that we see um the
so sample that we observe is you know
sampled according to some sort of
complex data collection process
so maybe
you know maybe samples are still
independent but it's not uh you know
it's not identical so maybe there's some
important sampling some elements of the
population have a higher probability of
participating in our sample than others
or you know maybe things are much worse
maybe the samples are very dependent um
whether a given
element of the population is in the
sample is correlated with whether other
things are
and you know there are obviously lots of
kind of real world sampling processes
where there are um
there's a lot more so structure and
correlations so one example is this kind
of snowball sample
um
or uh also known as have respondent
dribbling driven sampling
um which
uh so arises a lot in
social science surveys and some medical
type stuff where you basically uh well
you can think of it as there's some say
social network over the population
and
um
you know when one person responds to
your survey
there's some probability that
each of their friends also responds
okay
so this is like the
sort of thing where you know if you
respond to a survey i'm gonna say hey by
the way uh i'm gonna give you five
dollars for every friend of yours that
also uh everyone you refer to who fills
out the survey i'm gonna give you five
dollars and i'll give them five dollars
and so on
um
good
okay and again so
um
this sort of usual way that maybe people
think about um you know estimation and
learning is where we have these
distributional assumptions about the
data values
you know so each of the xi's is picked
from you know is a coin flip or
distributed like a gaussian or
something like that
um
and sure there are lots of
generalizations and sort of extensions
of this so
um kevin robust statistics
there's still this distributional
assumptions about some of the data right
so robust statistics you assume that
maybe a portion of your x's are drawn
from some nice distribution and maybe
you make no assumptions about the
remaining ones but
um
but instead we're going to think about
the kind of setting on the right
where we're not going to make
assumptions about the data values
about the xi's themselves the values
instead we're going to try to leverage
an understanding of the
sampling process the decision about
which xis are in our sample
and then we'll see exactly what we mean
by this
okay good so so let me let me just
redescribe the framework which was
basically the same framework we started
at the beginning so
suppose there are n entities so sorry i
drew these as people instead of as coins
um
each person say has a
hidden value so the ith person has some
value x i
let's think of this as a
bounded real number
we can think of it as being some vector
later on but for simplicity let's think
of it as just being a single
real number say bounded between -1 and
1.
our goal is going to be just to estimate
the mean of these
of these n values
and again we can think of other
statistics but let's deal with that
later
um
okay maybe i'll keep well okay we can
have a running example
on the right side of the screen
okay and then crucially um
let's assume that we have a there's some
known distribution p capital p
which is a distribution over subsets of
these n people
and we think of this as being kind of
the sampling
distribution so what happens
a subset of these n people is drawn
according to this sampling distribution
p
we observe who's in the subset and the
values you know the x's indexed by the
people in the subset
okay so in our running example suppose
you know the first 500 people are going
to respond to our survey with
probability 0.1
the next 500 people are going to respond
with probability 0.5
and
good
okay and um we're going to make a
prediction which is going to be a
function of this distribution this known
distribution over subsets p
as well as a function over well who ends
up being sampled and the values that we
see in that sample
and we're going to be trying to
find a function f
that
minimizes
the worst case expected error so we're
going to try to find a function
that minimizes
the worst case over the different values
that the people might have
of the expected error where the
expectation is over the randomness of
the subset that we actually have
um
okay and in this kind of important
sampling setting um you know there are
plenty of estimators that that'd be
reasonable right so a standard estimator
that just weights each of these samples
kind of five times more than these
samples
um
uh you know we'll end up having a small
um worst case expected error
yeah sorry there's a question
sorry this is just a minor clarification
so i mean
there's there's like this long line of
work in statistics which is about like
finite samples
or like finite populations and
randomization inference i'm just trying
to understand
is this
minimax estimation in that setting or is
there any difference
to that
sure so um
um
you can think about it
in that setting you could also think
about um there being a you know
accountably infinite underlying
population that
that doesn't really matter um this
notion of caring about the
you know worst case expected error um
it's not sort of the typical
um it's not the typical framework but
it's certainly you know i mean this
paper from 1950 and annals of statistics
was you know was also within that
framework um
so i mean i guess the the new thing that
we are trying to do
is
um
make
have one algorithm which takes this
distribution p and does the right thing
you know for every distribution p
will compute the optimal function
okay thanks thanks so much
so yeah so the framework is not uh
uh
yeah
actually i also have a question greg so
in your example i think p is a product
distribution if we treat
treat that as a distribution let's say
over the vertices of a binary hypercube
so yeah is there any example in your
mind where p is not a product
distribution
yeah good so uh i think i'll do that on
the i mean i'll have some examples on
the next slide i think okay great uh or
maybe two sides for now but uh if if i
don't answer that within five minutes
i'll come back
okay good so um
okay so so actually maybe there are two
tasks so one task is suppose someone
gives you an estimator f they describe
this function can you even compute
the worst k or computer approximate the
worst case expected error
can you tell me like what's the worst
data distribution sorry what what what's
the worst kind of data values for your
estimator
and then of course there's the you know
even harder task which is can you find
you know the
the best estimator the function f that
minimizes this kind of worst case
expected error okay so these two two uh
tasks that we might care about
um
good uh
okay
and and again i guess just to go back to
this running important sampling example
suppose you give me some algorithm say
the standard algorithm
the worst case data
um for this algorithm corresponds to
saying you know
what's the kind of
worst case way in which the data values
the x's
might be intertwined with these
probabilities of participating in the
survey
okay and and this is you know very like
from a practical standpoint this makes a
lot of sense right like
um
if somebody is going to participate in
your survey with probably 0.1 and
someone else might participate with
probably 0.5 presumably their data
values might also
you know can be drawn from very
different you know be quite different
reflecting the fact that these are
people who behave differently
and this worst case framework basically
is going to say look um we want our
algorithm to work even when
the values might be arbitrarily
you know sort of adversarially colluding
with these underlying probability
distributions
okay good um just i wanted to just
mention that you know everything we're
going to talk about also goes through
in this slightly more general setting
where
instead of trying to estimate the mean
of the population the mean of x1 to xn
suppose there's also some target set
um that's drawn according to some other
distribution
and we only care about the mean of this
target set
okay so
you can think about as the goal of
estimating the mean of
overall population or that you know
there's kind of some
you can think about the sample as being
uh you know a training set
and there being some other set t which
is the test set
and we're trying to estimate our
statistic on the test set given the data
in the training set um so anyway so so
the whole framework goes through in this
setting too and our results also go
through this setting
okay
okay good so let me give some
illustrative examples so
okay so we've already talked about these
um
first two so certainly this kind of um
important sampling and just this you
know independent coin flip setting
the underlying uh distribution of our
samples corresponds to this you know
this kind of product distribution where
each individual appears in the sample
independently
with maybe some you know individual
specific probability
um
you know something like this snowball
sampling
um
[Music]
uh
procedure um in this case the
um
you know this distribution capital p is
very far from a product distribution
just because you know if your friends
are in the sample it greatly increases
the chance that you'll be in the same
a different setting which
i wasn't planning to talk about too much
um is the
this kind of forecasting type
setting um where
um the
x1 through xn you should think of as
being sort of a chronological sequence
and
we're going to end up observing some
past theta x one through x sub t
and we're going to be asked to predict
something over some future set like x
sub t plus one through some other
x sub t plus w
and again in that case they're obviously
uh
um
uh
strong dependencies
um between you know which data points
are in the sample
um and so on
um
is that is that okay
okay
okay so let me um describe the main
results and i'll sort of sketch out how
the arguments go very briefly um so the
first theorem says
if you're given some estimator
f
then in polynomial time with a
polynomial number of samples
from this distribution over samples p so
so you know we don't need to know the
actual distribution p you just need some
polynomial number of samples
one can
get a pi over two approximate
approximation to the
worst case expected error of this
estimator
and and there's this um cavea at the end
as i'll mention in a second
um
and the second theorem is basically it's
saying that actually in polynomial time
not only can you
estimate
the worst case expected error but you
can find an estimator that optimizes
this again up to that same pi over 2
factor
and the
the caveat is that we're restricting
ourselves in both cases
to the set of
estimators
which i guess we're going to refer to as
semi-linear
and what does that mean
that means that
your estimator is going to be
some weighted combination of the values
you see
but where the weight you put on each
value can be some arbitrary function of
you know this distribution p as well as
the specific set of
of people who are in your sample
okay so you can think of it as
a set of estimators um before you see
the values if you just know the list of
people who are going to be in your
sample
this defines a set of coefficients and
then the and then you they reveal their
values and you output this kind of
linear combination of their
other values um
so i should say you know i can't think
of any
even vaguely reasonable
non-semi-linear estimators but um
um
but still this is a significant uh
restriction
okay good so so let me begin by
illustrating a little bit about kind of
what this problem is and sort of at
least alluding to the
combinatorial
structure of this problem
okay so suppose we're just looking at
this problem of someone gives you some
function f an estimator f and we're
trying to
figure out what's the worst case
data
you know for this algorithm okay what's
the worst case underlying x's that
maximize the expected
error of your estimator
okay so let me give you actually a very
special case of this problem
so suppose this distribution p
corresponds to the following suppose
there's just some underlying graph over
the n individuals
and
this distribution p is defined
implicitly as follows we're going to
pick an edge of the graph uniformly at
random
and
one of the endpoints
um sorry and i reveal the data value at
one of the endpoints of the edge and ask
you to predict the data value at the
other end point
so pick a random edge i tell you the
value at one end point your job is to
guess the value of the other endpoint
okay so suppose this is our distribution
p
and suppose i'm going to
tell you a trivial
it might not be a good algorithm but um
i'll tell you a simple estimation
algorithm namely just
whatever value you're told predict that
the other end point is equal
so suppose that's your estimation
algorithm someone tells you then point
of the edge and you predict that the
other endpoint is the same
what's the
worst case expected error
of this
uh of this estimate
namely suppose you know this is that
this is your estimator
and now it's your job to put say bounded
values say the values are bounded
between minus one and one your job is to
put the values minus one and one at the
endpoints of the graph so as to maximize
the
error of this of this estimator in
expectation over the randomness of p
namely over picking a random edge you're
trying to make these endpoints as
different as possible
is the graph by far side
uh it's safe for an arbitrary graph yeah
so what yeah what is this problem
um
yeah exactly right so so this is exactly
the max cut right so uh you know if the
values are need to be bounded between
minus one and one you'll put values
minus one and one at endpoints so as to
um
you know maximize the number of edges
that are cut
because then according to this
distribution p anytime you pick an edge
that's cut
the estimator will be kind of maximally
wrong
and if you pick an edge that's not cut
um
then you know your estimator will be uh
you know completely correct which is why
you're trying to maximize the
size of the cut
okay good so um
uh good so so this shows a few things
one is that all right i have a question
yeah so
how how did you get it exactly to max
cut because it's not that obvious that
everything should be minus one and one
right because you're comparing it to the
mean so
if if the max cut gave equal equal sizes
then i believe you like on each side
but maybe that would
yeah yeah drag the mean too much or
something yeah oh uh okay i'm sorry so
sorry so so this was in this um
sort of extension of the framework where
the goal is to estimate the
mean of the values indexed by the set t
as opposed to the mean of the overall
well i think the question is why does it
never make sense to have fractional
values
in between this one and one for the
adversary
um so
yeah so
so sorry so so um in the case where
um
okay so so
in the case where you know so as
described we were trying to just predict
this other endpoint we're not trying to
predict the overall mean of the values
in that case then this really
corresponds exactly to this
kind of max cut
relaxation
where you're allowed to put some you
know
you're logical value that's not um but
in that case you know it uh
um if you look at these like fractional
cuts you do want to make everything
binary
is that okay
yeah
um
um
yeah and and so even in the case where
you're trying to estimate the overall
mean of everything you can still embed
this sort of thing
um and get uh yeah it won't be exactly
mexican there'll be something a bit
different but you still get this np
hardness of exactly estimating this
worst case optimal
sorry the the um
worst case expected error
um
okay but um
but good so so there's hope because you
know at least there's a constant factor
approximation of um of max cut
and maybe you know
uh maybe we should hope for some
constant factor approximation
um you know in general for this uh you
know for this estimation problem
and
okay and and so this this ends up
panning out
and basically let me
let me very
quickly sketch what's
um
what's going on so
um so i claim that that
um
given some
estimator f
you know what
if the estimator f looks like there's a
um
estimator f has a semi-linear property
namely that as a function of
you know the set we're given in this
case s and t and the distribution p
um
if there's a set of coefficients such
that we'll end up outputting this
weighted average of the of x's
um then we can basically write a so
generalization of the gorman's
williamson stp
um that will yield this this camp pi
over two approximation
um
and
um so i guess what's the right way of
thinking about this
well we're still trying to assign
um
see values between minus one and one uh
to these to these n different
you know x one through x n
and for every different um sample s
uh
in the support of our distribution t
um
that's going to induce some sort of uh
you know loss term
and
you know we can end up just writing down
um you know what this ends up being and
this doesn't look so different from um
you know the they have the natural
um
the max cut problem for which say the
gorman's williams and stp applies
and then there are a couple of issues so
one is that maybe this is some
exponential size spp because we have an
exponential number of sets in the
support of p
but this isn't two bit too much of a
issue because you can argue that well if
you just sample some polynomial size
number of these subsets
both the solution and the value of stp
shouldn't change by too much
um
and then
to go from being able to estimate the
value of this to actually finding
um finding an optimal estimator
this is sort of a convex duality thing
so rather than
thinking about
minimizing over the functions f
maximizing over the data values x
and so on you can switch the order of
these things via convex duality and end
up sort of analyzing things in it and it
ends up kind of directly reducing to
this um positive semi-definite growth in
the problem
um which is kind of where the pi over 2
comes from if you're if you're familiar
with that
um
okay so
let's see um
so i should wrap up pretty soon is that
okay i forgot exactly when we began but
uh
i have five more minutes
ten more minutes
uh yeah i think we have uh maybe ten
more minutes yeah okay good okay
um
okay so
here
let me just say a few things so
even though we end up with some
you know so theoretically we end up with
some fairly large sdp
um one can actually implement this
and the resulting algorithm actually
ends up working quite nicely in a number
of um
you know so settings that we've
experimented with
so um
let's see
right so so for for a couple of
different settings you know one is just
a simple important sampling setting
another is a snowball sampling setting
another is kind of predicting the future
forecasting setting um the kind of sdp
solution we end up with corresponds to
an algorithm with you know with a decent
constant factor better performance than
kind of the standard things
um let me maybe just talk about the
important sampling setting because
that's the one where
i was most surprised that
anything interesting happens
okay so um
again so think of this important
sampling setting concretely there are 50
people
the first 25 will respond to a survey
which will
be present in our sample
independently with probability 0.1
the next 25 people
are in the sample independently with
probably 0.5
so
um
there are sort of two standard
important sampling estimators
one of them is re-weighting namely
you know the
first 25 people they each respond um
you know uh one-fifth as often as the
second so let's just re-weight their
contributions um to fix this so that you
know for each of the people in the first
half let's weight them
five times more than the people in the
second half
so that's this kind of rewaiting
algorithm
the other natural approach is to say
look there are two different
subpopulations there's a population that
responds with probably 0.1 there's a
population that responds to value 0.5
let's estimate the mean of each of these
separately
and then let's just return the average
of the
means of these two separate populations
so that's what i mean by this subgroup
estimation algorithm
and from a worst case data standpoint
both these rewaitings are
sorry both the reweighting and the
subgroup estimation are you know maybe a
factor of two worse than what the stp
algorithm gives us
and
um
for these two algorithms it's not too
hard to see what the worst case data
ends up looking like
so
suppose everybody in one of these you
know you know uh everyone in the first
set of people
say they all have values plus one and
everyone in the second set has values
say minus one
so in that case if you're doing this
re-weighting where you weight the people
in the first half um
so five times more than people in second
half um
you're going to end up paying quite a
lot in terms of the variance and how
many people you end up with in the first
half first the second half
and that's why this re-weighting is so
bad
on the other
on the other hand if you do this
subgroup estimation
as long as you get at least one person
from each of these groups you get zero
error
and this tiny error here is due to just
the small probability that you don't get
anyone
with from one of these groups and it'll
probably be from this first
however if each of these populations has
you know plus and minus you know so say
equal-ish numbers of plus and minus ones
then the subgroup estimation ends up
being
um
problematic because you don't get very
many samples from this first group so
there's a lot of variance in your
estimate in this first group
and um
you know the kind of this stp algorithm
in both you know these bad cases does
pretty
you know it does pretty well um it ends
up being kind of uh
you know ends up being have a
regularized version of
uh
well sort of a regularized version of
this subgroup estimation but it ends up
being something
um
that's interpretable but but fairly
unorthodox um but it seems to work you
know work much better
okay uh let me skip the snowball
sampling stuff and uh
um
good
um
okay in terms of use cases for this um
so obviously this was sort of presented
in the case where like we know this
underlying distribution p
um
you know
in most real life cases maybe we don't
know the sampling distribution p
although in some in sort of designing
clinical trials or some polling type
settings maybe we do control the
sampling procedure and then there are
these questions of well how do we you
know how can we design a sampling
procedure p subject to some conditions
um which will actually guarantee that we
have a good estimator
the vast majority of use cases we
probably don't actually know the
underlying distribution p
however in most of these cases we you
know could certainly dream up various
plausible p's and it would be worth
stress testing the estimators you plan
to use
in light of the time the worst case
performance with respect to plausible
distributions p and i think this third
case is really the main
um
sort of area of application of this sort
of framework
good so um
there's tons of open questions related
to this um
let me let me just say one thing so um
in many cases
um
there's no
uh
there's no pi over two gap so if you run
our stp on say the the problem we began
with where you're just trying to come up
with this worst case optimal estimator
for the bias of a coin
then um you end up with
exactly that right answer which is that
formula from the 1950 uh you know annals
of statistics paper
um and it would be nice to have a sort
of characterization of which
distributions p
um
don't you know
which ones don't lose this constant
factor in the optimality
another kind of interesting point is you
know
our theorems had this caveat that they
only applied to semi-linear algorithms
via some computer search we found some
setting
um for which
a non-semi-linear algorithm actually was
better than
the you know any semi-linear algorithm
but the the gap the biggest gap we could
find is this factor of 1.004
and you know i strongly believe that uh
there's a constant factor
um
that this gap can never be more than
some small constant factor
um
okay i think i think that's that's a
natural um
that's a natural place to
uh
please stand
thank you correct for the grace talk so
yeah any questions
hi greg thanks for the great talk um
so i wanted to ask a question about um
whether you have a sense for
when we use these kinds of worst case
procedures how much it might be
sacrificing on like a typical
case scenario and i asked the question
because i sort of
if i remember correctly from my
courses on statistical theory when i
first learned this hodges layman kind of
thing
um
that it's like sometimes used as an
example to not
take minimax results too
literally or seriously right because it
ends up super optimizing that worst case
error at the expense of
increasing the risk for a lot of other
parameters
that might occur so i was wondering just
in the sense from for dsp for the sdp
approaches that you designed whether you
have a sense of the extent of that
trade-off yeah so
um
so i was going to say so one nice thing
about this framework is that um
you can you can find the you know you
can see the worst case distributions the
stp will give you these worst case
things sorry the worst case data values
and then you know you can decide for
yourself it is it reasonable
so for the um
like for the important sampling
uh setting
like the you know the the sort of worst
case for this subgroup estimation really
is this thing where just the population
is uniform like everywhere and has
values plus minus one equally mixed
and that certainly seems very reasonable
the um worst case for
uh for this kind of re-weighting setting
you know ends up being this um
completely uniform within each group but
the groups are maximally different
um and you know you could argue that
that's
yeah maybe not super realistic but it's
also not so different i mean if if you
have some subgroups that have different
probabilities of participating in a poll
you know what's to say that the value
you care about isn't also correlated
with you know which of these groups
you're in right
um so so you know in this case the worst
case for kind of these two things ends
up being very natural
and like a worst case thing for stp is
um
i think actually
it ends up being sort of
the sdp is kind of trying to trade off
performance on these two things
so
maybe the worst case ends up being lots
of
like everything in between these two
extreme points
so in this case at least if you look at
stp and you ask what's the worst case
distribution for that you get like lots
of different data values
which are all worst case
and so this maybe you see
tells you that things are okay
um
for um a snowball sampling type thing so
you say you have some
um some spatial sort of snowball
sampling like your points think of these
as being people in some geographic space
and close by people
you know
have some increased probability of uh
you know if someone near you
participates that increases your prop
your probability of participating
then um the worst case
data
for sort of almost anything natural but
including the stp thing ends up being
some spatially correlated values so
maybe
you know up in the upper right corner
everyone's values
near minus one and lower left everyone's
values count plus one
and again this seems you know this seems
pretty natural like if you uh
don't sample these people in the lower
left at all then
you know it's uh
maybe maybe they're very different than
the people in the upper right and
um
you know
um
but yeah so so
um at least for some of these examples
you know you can look at these worst
case uh
data values and think about how
realistic is it um although i did you
know one of these
have the last open question
is you know maybe new and practical
blends of this model with more
traditional models um so so yeah this
last point was trying to get at the
um is there something that's maybe
not as pessimistic as its worst case
but still allows for
bad sorts of correlations between
you know who ends up being in your
sample
sorry bad correlations between countries
your sampling distribution and
underlying values that you care about
and i don't have any great
candidate hybrids
um
yet but i think it's it's worth thinking
about
sorry that was a long answer longer than
people wanted
uh thanks for a great talk so the uh
i mean when i think about for instance
political polling
or for that matter of snowball sampling
it seems like the problem is we in both
cases we don't know p
um and worse and maybe there's nothing
to be done about this
people's probability of responding is
actually correlated with the value they
have
um
and
so that you know in a sense the
adversary first gets to choose the
values
and then gets to choose to some extent
the
distribution of subsets
and uh maybe that second part there's
just nothing to be done because
you know i could just say well some
fraction of the people who have this
value just don't ever respond and
whatever but for the first thing i i
mean i was excited about the fact that
your uh
your randomized algorithm you're sort of
sub sampling
the stp talked about samples from p
so if you're taking samples from p
anyway
then
what doesn't why doesn't this apply to a
setting where you don't know p but where
you're able to
try this polling process many times and
get a sense of the distribution of
subsets
okay so
good so that so that's perfect so um
yeah so you don't need to know p but you
need to be able to get samples from it
um
and again these samples from
sorry these samples you know you don't
need the x's for them right you just
need to know who's in the sample right
you don't need the data values you just
need to know who's in the sample
um
so um
you know so so again so
so
um
i think for in terms of the political
polling setting i think the hard part i
mean this does apply to that setting i
think the hard part though is that um
we don't have many samples from p
in the sense that um p changes very uh
very rapidly right so the big surprise
from this past election for example was
um you know the the um
uh you know cuban-american voters in
florida who who suddenly sort of uh
um voted and you know had a high turnout
and voted republican okay but but just
from the perspective of p
that's that's really like
uh
we had no we had no idea that that this
set of people were gonna turn out in
such high numbers right um
and
oh sorry yeah it's sorry i mean i think
maybe florida
cuban americans tend to vote um
they tend to do it sorry they tend to
turn out
to vote often um
but uh
um but anyway okay so maybe the surprise
was just how they voted but um but but i
think the the fact that we don't have
that many
data points is um
is kind of one of the
limitations with trying to apply this to
the polling setting
i guess the other issue is also
um
from a polling standpoint
the probability of people participating
is so low
i mean like we're talking about
um you know a given person in the us
probably doesn't have a phone
and you know the probability of them
ending up in one of these polls is or
responding to a poll is you know
less than one or two percent
um and i think that's really the
um
uh
that's really the issue there are lots
of people where basically the
probability of them participating is
zero
and for that huge demographic there's
nothing you can do
yeah thank you correct and maybe we can
have one more question
uh yeah actually i i have a quick
question on your important sampling
example yeah could you
yeah did you have a sense of what the of
the week
what is the final estimator given by the
stp
algorithm look like
good yeah so um
so what does it do it um
um
right okay so okay you can think about
it as it tries to fix the issue with
subgroup estimation
and the issue with re-weighting so um
think of it as suppose you start with
subgroup estimation so you're going to
compute the
estimate
of the you know the mean on the left
half
based on the people on the left half
you'll compute estimate of the mean on
the right half based on the people on
the right half and then just output the
average of those two
okay so so
what is it going to do um
it's going to
instead of outputting the empirical
means of these it's going to regularize
each of these means separately
according to you know how big the sample
was like if you only get one person from
the left half
then
[Music]
you should you should do basically what
we did on the very first slide without
putting one fourth or three quarters
instead of something else if you only
have one sample right
so we're going to regularize our
estimate
of each
half separately
but then also
if we get lots of samples from the right
half and very few from the left half
our time variance of the left half is
going to be bigger too so we're going to
also slightly regularize the the mixing
rates
so that's kind of what the sdp thing
does it um
so again like like the answer
the estimate will depend on the
empirical averages of these two halves
as well as the number of people in each
half that ended up uh being in our
sample
and it's going to do the right sort of
regularizations in that uh
you know
i see so
yeah so do you have a sense of lesson of
the last expression because i think the
way it only depends on the basically
that's the number of samples in each
group
so could you could we have a sense of
the let's say how the expression looks
like from let's say from the
practical ssdb algorithm
yeah so okay
yeah so it's it's um
it's not a
um
in contrast to this to the
regularization
it was just estimating a single
coin this like
one over you know square root k plus one
i think in contrast to that it is
actually some sort of complicated
combination of the number of samples in
one group and the number in another so
it's not it's not something super super
simple um
and
um
yeah yeah so it's not it's not like a
linear function of the two sample means
or
anything yeah thank you
um
okay perhaps we can thank greg again for
the great talk
yeah
yeah
and let's also thank the organizers of
this workshop including the lawrence
laurent colleen and jamie and all
speakers for the great talk and have a
nice weekend
thank you craig thank you yeah i'll stay
on if anyone wants to say hi